hello believe nation i started the
mentor me series with the goal to spend
a little more time with people who've
done
a lot more than us and hopefully some of
their magic pixie dust
rubs off onto us so we can absorb their
wisdom
learn how to change our mindset and go
for greatness
so today we're going to learn from will
smith on how to stay motivated
i i believe uh and i learned very young
from parents from my parents absolutely
that
you you don't try to build a wall
you don't set out to build a wall you
don't say i'm gonna
build the biggest baddest greatest wall
that's ever been built you don't start
there you say
i'm gonna lay this brick as perfectly
as a brick can be laid there will not be
one brick on the face of the earth
that's going to be laid better than this
brick that i'm going to lay
in this next 10 minutes and you do that
every single day and soon you have a
wall
and i think psychologically the
advantage that
that gives me over over a lot of people
that i
have been in competition with in
different situations
is it's difficult to take the first step
when you look how
big yeah the the task is the task is
never huge to me
it's always one breath me too i mean
it's amazing how
you know people are paralyzed from doing
anything
absolutely because they can't take the
first step as you just say look all i'm
doing is laying this one brick i am not
building the great wall of china right
here
absolutely putting a brick here and i'm
going to have the best brick i can your
father
i think i realized absolutely had you
and your brother
work on a ball oh yeah yeah we that
we're talking about our figurative wall
that that comes from work on a literal
wall yeah right
my father owned um it actually was an
old bakery when i was growing up my
my father was uh an electrician and a
refrigeration man we would we would
install supermarkets you see the long
freezer cases
in supermarkets we would install those
long freezer cases and
all the lights that's what we that's
what we would do every summer
yeah so this uh this one year my father
had his shop
and he decided for whatever reason
that he wanted a new wall on
the front of his shop so he tore down
probably about
you know 16 feet high and probably about
30 feet long he just completely tore the
wall down
and my brother and i had to dig a six
foot hole
for the foundation we were mixing the
concrete by hand
a year and a half we were building this
wall for a year and a half
every day after school we were coming
mixing concrete putting it in the hole
doing it
and it was just myself and my little
brother
and i remember standing back looking at
that wall saying
there's going to be a hole here forever
there will never be anything here and
a year and a half later that many days i
know a year and a half later
we laid the the final brick yeah
and my father stood back with my brother
and i and i know he planned this he says
he
he says he didn't but i know he had been
planning this and writing this
for his uh for the past two years
but he we stood back we looked at the
wall and he looked at me and my brother
said don't y'all never tell me that you
can't do something
and walked into the shop as a child my
parents always told me you could be
whatever you want to be you could do
whatever you want to do
and you know that that office that
position
the highest office on the face of the
earth
it was something i heard my parents
saying it but i didn't totally believe
it yet i went out in the world and i
carried myself
and i held my head high and i stood
there and i looked people in their eyes
and i talked to people
as if i was deserving of everything that
this planet has to offer
so i just i really want to say to to
children out there
and to to people who are watching
confucius said one time
he who says he can and he who says he
can't are both usually right
so i want to stand here before you and
as i hold this award
i want to give love to my wife and i
want you to keep in your heart just know
that you can
know that you can the separation of
talent
and skill is one of the the the greatest
misunderstood concepts for people who
are trying to excel who have dreams that
want to do things
talent you have naturally skill is only
developed
by hours and hours and hours of beating
on your craft
i've never really viewed myself as
particularly
talented where i excel is
ridiculous sickening
work ethic you know while the other guys
sleeping
i'm working what other guys eating i'm
working
there's no easy way around it no matter
how talented
you are your talent is going to fail you
if you're not skilled
you know if you don't study if you don't
work uh
really hard and dedicate yourself to
being better every single day
you'll never be able to communicate with
with people with your artistry the way
that you want the only thing
that i see that is
distinctly different about me is
i'm not afraid to die on a treadmill
you might have more talent than me you
might be smarter than me
but if we get on the treadmill together
right
there's two things you're getting off
first yeah or i'm gonna
die it's really that simple
everybody who became an actor became an
actor because
it got something to say uh that's very
interesting i never uh
never intellectualized it that way but
that that is very true
for me it it has been
the to be that guy
that does what people say can't be done
you know and i think it started with uh
trying to please my mother and trying to
please
my grandmother and they always wanted
higher for me they always wanted
more for me and it got to the point that
i wanted to be something i wanted to be
somebody
and it it made me
choose certain roles it made me
turn down certain roles
there is more than an image that i want
to project
i want to be the person that is the
first person there
and the last person to leave that's who
i want to be because i think that
the the road to success is through
commitment and through the strength
to drive through that commitment when it
gets hard
and it is going to get hard and you're
going to want to quit sometimes but
it'll be colored by who you are
and more who you want to be i definitely
found that
wanting to be an actor stems from
wanting to be
somebody and wanting to say something to
people
there's a certain delusional quality
that all successful people
have to have you have to believe that
something
different than what has happened for the
last
50 million years of history you have to
believe
that something different can happen yeah
it's almost a kind of innocence
absolutely not in other words if you
knew how difficult it was
right you would have never gone down
that path absolutely you know if
somebody said to ali no one can beat
this guy he's this much stronger is this
much bigger he's got that much bigger
punch than you do
and he believed that he would have said
never you've got to have an innocent
person
somehow absolutely and i think that
that's a huge part
of me because and i say
to my friends all the time and
we we laugh about it i truly
honestly as i sit here before you right
now
as honestly as i can say it to you i
truly believe that i could be the
president if i wanted to
and as bizarre as that may sound to
people that have
traveled the path before me and to
people who actually know how difficult
it is
foolish will smith honestly believes
[Music]
anytime you inject extremes into
the universe you can expect extremes
to to come back um i think
that you know one of the best pieces of
advice i ever got was
uh don't let your successes go to your
head
and don't let your failures go to your
heart do you follow that
uh i try no it is
it it's absolutely um
a difficult uh eve
more so now with my my wife and my
children
expanding into it the
the scope of it is actually becoming
more difficult
to manage the things that
uh almost in a spiritual sense the
things that you attract
to yourself um and
also if you think about it in terms of
altitude the higher you go the harder it
is to breathe
there's less oxygen and i think with in
that phrase what i get from that with
marlon brando what what happens is if
you think about it in terms of mountain
climbing
mountain climbing the higher and the
higher you get the less oxygen
there is the harder it is to breathe as
you get to this successful space
and the first thing people want to do is
get down and what you
do by getting down is self-destructive
and i'm just working hard to make sure
that i don't allow the lack of
oxygen to dull
my appreciation for the gifts i've been
getting
one of my favorite books is the the
alchemist
uh paulo coelho and
that's just i just believe that i
believe
that i can create whatever
i want to create if i can put put my
head on it right
study it learn the patterns and
you know i just i it's hard to put into
words real
metaphysical esoteric nonsense but i
feel
very strongly that we are who we choose
to be
i consider myself an alchemist an
alchemist
is basically a mystical
chemist right and one of the great feats
that alchemists used to do is they would
take
lead just take a chunk of lead and they
could turn lead into gold
right so the symbolism that's like a
good hustle
all right no right that i leave
you know but i so connected to
symbolically
uh being able to turn lead into gold
you know my grandmother used to say you
know life give you a lemon you go ahead
and make lemonade absolutely
to me that's that's alchemy that's
that's the same concept
behind the the the alchemist but for me
i never did anything for money right so
never it was never
about money um my experience has been
when people do
things for money you make bad choices
buy what you
love and then you'll learn how to make
money doing
what you i love when i changed careers
i was never changing to something for
money i was changing to something i
loved more right and that to me that's
really the only way to keep passion if
you have two choices
and one is playing
and you can make more money bowling but
you love playing the piano more
you got to play the piano it's like
you'll tear yourself apart if you're not
doing the thing that you love
most in life and you know what it is
right now
right now there's something that you
love more than everything
whatever it is that you love crazy has
to be the thing that you dedicate your
life it's
unrealistic to walk in a
but unfortunately the rank brothers and
others didn't
didn't believe that and it just seems
it just seems like such a ridiculous
idea to me
to embrace the idea
that it's not gonna happen that's not
real for
that to happen as soon as you say it now
you just think that real
fear is not
real
the only place that fear can exist is
in our thoughts of the future
it is a product of our imagination
causing us to fear things that do not at
present
and may not ever exist
that is near insanity qatar
now do not misunderstand me danger
is very real but fear is a
choice
[Music]
we are all telling ourselves a story
thank you guys so much for watching i
love to know what you thought of the
clip i'd love to know which one
resonated the most with you and why
leave it down in the comments really
appreciate you guys watching
continue to believe and i'll see you
soon
greatness is not this um
wonderful esoteric elusive
uh god like feature
that only the special among us
uh will ever taste you know it's
something that truly exists
in all of us it's very simple
this is what i believe and
i'm willing to die for it yeah period
it's that simple i know who i am i don't
know what i believe i know who i am i
know who whatever
i need to know that's all i need to know
so from there
you do what you need to do yeah you know
and i think what happens is
we make this situation more complex than
it has to be because we're looking for
complexity there's got to be something
complex to understand
it can't be that easy to be able to be
vulnerable in front of anybody
you know you have to be comfortable
looking silly
you have to be comfortable making
mistakes and you have to break the thing
inside of you that doesn't
want people to see right because as soon
as you allow people to see
all of a sudden you get access to things
that you didn't realize you had access
to
right um for example like the thing i
used to do
is when i was in probably 18 or 19 years
old
i got in touch with those blocks the
camera hates
emotional blocks like you put a camera
in somebody's face
and they're uncomfortable about
delivering emotion it looks fake and you
feel it
you immediately know it's not real right
um
especially look at the size of this
screen and in a shot that whole screen
could be just your
eyes right so it's like you can't
hide discomfort uncertainty so you have
to be able
to get comfortable you know just being
anything
anything that you have to be for the
role
you have to be comfortable being it